tensions have been rising between the
residents of these apartment blocks and
the local people in lundergran I after
the buildings were placed under lockdown
due to dozens of coronavirus cases
several residents tried to leave in
defiance of the order and this could be
a big problem for us because after they
gonna close all the city and then is a
economic problem for us most of the
residents are Bulgarians
many of them thought to be working in
Italy without proper contracts and for
very low wages
now sentiment against the foreign
workforce is mounting agricultural
workers they come each season then they
move on to Greece for the olive harvest
before these seasonal workers arrived
there was no kovat here now dozens of
police have been sent to Mondragon II to
ease tensions and stop residents from
leaving the building to keep the virus
contained the Red Cross is carrying out
extensive testing hundreds of samples
have already been taken I must say that
Mandar Oni is responding very very well
a lot of people are coming for tests
since we started this morning we've
taken over 250 swaps people understood
here how important it is to be careful
about the virus now a National
Protection Agency is delivering food to
the quarantined residents they will not
be able to leave their homes for the
next 15 days now joined by journalist
Seema Gupta inspir longa around 50
kilometers from Mondragon a Seema
greetings
why has the new corona outbreak happened
among agricultural workers
well these agricultural workers this
essentially seasonal workers they come
to Italy in order to harvest crops
at the time when the crops are ready and
so they often unfortunately is we also
heard in that report they are often
exploited they have poor working
conditions they paid very little and
they live in abandoned apartment
buildings in the area which have
unfortunately poor sanitary conditions
and so it becomes easy for the fire is
to spread among this particular group so
now this apartment complex where the
unliving has been put under quarantine
they've conducted more than 700 tests on
the people that they're living there and
they found only three positive cases of
carbon 19 that's mainly the Bulgarian
seasonal workers but also nine homeless
Italians that were squatting in that
building there have been tensions
between the inhabitants of the apartment
complex and the residents of want
they're gonna go upset about the fact
that their town is in the headlines for
this region reason and so that's why
we've also seen that they challenge
government has decided send soldiers in
to try and control the situation and
make sure those who are under quarantine
stay coats for the next 15 days clearly
a developing situation there I'm curious
Seema are officials there also seeing
rising cases among the other residents
of the city well what they're doing now
is that they're testing all some 30,000
residents of mantra gonna because they
say they want to put the situation under
control
the governor of Campania region Vincenzo
DeLuca who has been very vocal
throughout this outbreak about wanted to
control the cases in his region of
Campania and said that they're tracking
down everyone including the group of
Bulgarian workers who had decided to
leave the area because they said they
need to work they need to work in order
to feed their families
in any case they'll be tracked down and
they've tested negative so they're
continuing to test and the
if he finds a hundred cases he's gonna
lock down the entire town you'd have to
be living under a rock not to know that
Italy was central to this whole pandemic
story here in Europe in general how
effective have the Italian authorities
been in containing Corona especially now
that the main travel season has begun
well what the government and the
authorities regional authorities are
trying to do is to make sure that people
stick to the self-protection measures
such as wearing those masks when you're
indoors social distancing as well as you
know hand sanitizer jobs being available
so that people keep to those important
century conditions and they're
identifying clusters like mantra gonna
like another cluster up north in bolonia
in a courier transport services company
in which they found some 64 cases most
of them without any symptoms at all
so essentially they've found some 10
towns in total now that have clusters or
hotspots in there they are clamping down
on those and making sure that they
control the spread in that area and for
the moment that's what they're hoping to
do in order to contain the spread but
you're right it's the travel season now
it's summer and so even more they're
saying people have to be vigilant Seema
Gupta there in Sperling ah many thanks
for that
you